so we have three different possible
production possibilities curve for
rabbits and berries here which we've
already talked about in other videos but
the reason why I'm showing you three
different curves is because these three
different curves clearly have different
shapes and we want to think about why
you would have what and under what
scenarios would you have these different
shapes here are production possibilities
curve or our PPC it looks like a
straight line here it looks like it's
bowed out from the origin it looks like
it's popping out in that direction and
here it looks like it's bowed in to the
origin it's popping in in this direction
so the first thing I'm going to do is
ask you a question which one describes a
scenario where for every extra rabbit I
catch every incremental rabbit I'm
giving up more and more in terms of
berries or another way of thinking about
it is as I catch more and more rabbits
the opportunity cost in terms of berries
is increasing which one of these curves
describes that well some of you might
have already seen the video on Khan
Academy on increasing opportunity cost
and you might recognize that this curve
here but let's just review it so there's
a world where I'm eating all berries and
I can get and I can pick 300 berries a
day but maybe I decide to go after that
first rabbit that just likes to hang out
and play with my knives and so when I
catch that it's very easy to catch so I
don't give up a lot in terms of berries
especially because I'm probably not on
the berries I'm giving up or probably
the ones that are hardest to pick and so
let's say that first rabbit the
opportunity cost I pick 20 less berries
so notice when I increase the rabbits by
one my berries go down by 20 so my
opportunity cost is 20 berries for that
first rabbit but let's say that second
rabbit is a little bit harder to catch
and I'm not giving up the quite so hard
to pick berries and so when I picked
that next or what I hunt that next
rabbit I should say then I've given up
40 berries so notice my opportunity cost
has increased for that first rabbit my
opportunity cost was 20 berries for that
second rabbit my opportunity cost is 40
berries and it keeps going then third
rabbit I'm going to give up 60 berries
that fourth rabbit I'm
give up 80 berries 80 berries and then
last but not least that fifth rabbit
which is the most that I can hunt in a
day I'm gonna give up a hundred berries
because here I'm going after the really
nimble rabbit the really sly rabbit and
I'm giving up literally the low-hanging
fruit in terms of berries the one I
might be even they might be on the
ground just ready for me to pick up and
so the important realization from this
video is this bowed out shape right over
here this is describing an increasing
opportunity costs let me write that down
increasing increasing oc4 opportunity
cost so with that out of the way which
of these would describe a decreasing
opportunity cost maybe you can imagine a
scenario where every incremental rabbit
I catch I get better and better at
catching rabbits
well you might guess that well look if
this one is increasing and I'm bowed out
then being bowed in would be a
decreasing opportunity cost decreasing
opportunity cost and let's make sure
that that makes sense
so we could go back to the scenario
where we're doing nothing but picking
berries and let's say that first rabbit
so we're gonna talk about a different
scenario now that first rabbit I had to
train myself to be able to get rabbits I
had to buy the tools I had to stretch
it's real it takes me a lot of effort to
get that first that first rabbit and so
there I give up 100 berries so my
opportunity cost for that first rabbit
was a hundred berries but then for that
second rabbit my opportunity cost is 80
berries maybe now I've kind of gotten
the hang of it I've already bought my my
rabbit catching shoes I've already
invested in that I've already I'm all
stretched stretched and limber maybe you
know those rabbits like to hang out
together and so that keeps on going so
that third rabbit my opportunity cost is
60 berries I'm getting really good at
catching rabbits so clearly you see here
that for each incremental rabbit I get
my opportunity cost is decreasing all
the way to that fifth rabbit maybe my
opportunity cost is 20 is 20 berries to
catch that next extra rabbit I'm giving
up those 20 berries so very clearly you
see a decreasing opportunity cost and
by deductive reasoning you might be able
to say well okay this straight line must
represent a constant opportunity cost
and that is indeed what it shows for
every rabbit every rabbit you catch
you're giving up exactly
you're giving up exactly 60 berries
every time I catch a rabbit I give up 60
berries so my opportunity cost for
rabbits in terms of berries is just a
constant 60 and so this is a scenario if
you were imagine in this this fictional
world we created where you know every
rabbit is about as easy to catch as any
other one and every berry is about as
easy to pick as in or find as any other
one and so the trade-off the amount of
time I spent for each incremental rabbit
I'm giving up a fixed amount of berries
no matter how many rabbits I go for and
no matter how many work no matter how
many berries I am currently at so that's
a constant opportunity cost when you
have a straight line